May Garden prep guide essential tips for
preparing your garden for planting
spring is in full swing and it's time to
prepare our garden for planting in May
grab your gloves and let's get our hands
dirty step one clear out winter debris
start by removing Dead Leaves twigs and
old mulch your garden needs a fresh
canvas step two soil
enrichment mix in compost or well-
rotted manure to enrich the soil healthy
soil equal healthy plants step three
planning your layout sketch out a layout
for your crops and flowers companion
planting works wonders step four check
watering system make sure your
irrigation system is ready to keep your
plants hydrated All Season step five
sunlight
exposure position your beds where they
will receive adequate sunlight for
optimal growth step six plant selection
choose plants suitable for your climate
and the season May is perfect for
tomatoes peppers and maragold tip rotate
your crops from last year to prevent
soil depletion final touches add mulch
around plants to retain moisture and
reduce weeds label your plants to keep
track of your
varieties plan for vertical growth using
trellises And staks subscribe now for
more gardening tips and tricks and
follow my journey as we create a
thriving May Garden together hit that
like button if you're ready to grow and
share this video with fellow gardening
enthusiasts happy gardening everyone
[Music]